Speaker 1: Something super interesting is
going on in the wake of Fox News firing.
Tucker Carlson As Fox struggles to find a
suitable replacement which we'll talk about
more a little bit later on in the show as
Fox continues to try to beat off other lawsuits,
current and potentially future related to
Tucker Carlson's programing and what's going
on behind what went on behind the scenes at
his show.
We have additional leaks that reveal Tucker's
displeasure, to put it very like likely lightly,
with elements of Fox News.
This is a Media Matters report.
Fox Leaks.
Tucker Carlson slammed Fox Nation in behind
the scenes video.
This article is by former David Pakman show
guest Matt Gertz, not Matt Gaetz.
Often confused.
This is by Matt Gertz, and it says Tucker
Carlson headlined Fox News is Fox Nation streaming
service in the years leading up to his sudden
firing.
But a behind the scenes video obtained by
Media Matters shows him lashing out at Fox
for the service's unbelievable failings, apparently
while doing some in that image rehab for misogynistic
social media influencer Andrew Tate.
Now, I have to tell you, we're going to look
at the clip here of what Tucker had to say
about Fox Nation.
It's a pretty damn accurate criticism of Fox
Nation.
Fox Nation is the streaming little brother
or sister of Fox News, the network channel.
And let's listen to what Tucker had to say.
It's very, very interesting.
Speaker 2: I don't want to be a slave to Fox
Nation, which I don't think that many people
watch Anyway, we're going to because I you
know, I'm like a representative of the American
media now, Right.
I was speaking to an exile in Romania and
welcoming him back into the brotherhood of
journalists that we got here.
It would help us all if he wore sweater, though.
Speaker 3: Because we ask him not to wear
a suit like he was panicking about it so you
don't have to talk is going to be looking
casual.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So first of all, this is just endlessly funny.
Apparently, what they're talking about is,
you know, the guy, Andrew Tate, who was arrested
for a while, and I don't even know what's
going on with him.
I don't I don't follow Andrew Tate.
Andrew Tate, I guess, normally wear suits
on interviews.
And it seems as though they're trying to convince
Tucker for this Fox Nation thing to wear a
sweater so that he is equally casual to what
they're expecting Andrew Tate to wear.
I think that's what I'm understanding here.
And Tucker is just getting annoyed.
Speaker 2: Yes.
What is that?
Okay.
What do we do with that?
I mean, I mean, this is airing on the nighttime
show and I want it to look official.
I don't want it to be like bro talk.
And I and I you know what I mean?
Give it the majority of it.
I don't.
Speaker 3: Like it.
We go like 45 minutes.
It's going to be for Fox.
Speaker 2: But nobody's going to watch it
on Fox Nation.
Nobody watches Fox Nation because the site
sucks.
Speaker 1: This is just the best that, you
know, I actually I do not sympathize with
Tucker on almost anything, but I've been in
situations where, like, you know, I'll have
a direct affiliation with some entity and
then that entity has some other affiliation
and they end up making requests for things
they want me to do, like at a conference.
And I know that my contacts are really just
being bugged by these other folks who I don't
really want to have anything to do with.
And they make these requests.
And the the frustration with Tucker about
they're trying to make me do stuff that's
really not good for me and it's not good for
anybody, and nobody's going to watch it anyway.
I really empathize with that specifically.
Beyond that, you all know my feelings about
Tucker.
Speaker 2: So I'd really like to just put
the dump the whole thing on YouTube.
But anyway, that's just my view.
I'm just frustrated with.
It's hard to use that site.
I don't know why they're not fixing it.
It's driving me insane.
And they're like, making like, Lifetime movies.
But they don't.
They don't work on the infrastructure of the
site.
Like what?
It's crazy.
And it drives me crazy because it's like we're
doing all this extra work and no one can find
it.
It's unbelievable.
Actually, I don't know who runs that site,
but.
Speaker 3: A sizable chunk on the show tomorrow
night.
That's the plan.
I don't know.
What he's going to do is drive a lot of people
to watch this on.
Fox Nation is gonna be a great help.
What we're doing over there.
Speaker 2: Today, I know, but we're doing
our part.
We're like working like animals to produce
all this content and the people in charge
of it, whoever that guy's, whatever his name
is, like, they're ignoring the fact that the
site doesn't work.
And it's I think it's like a betrayal of our
efforts.
That's how I feel.
So I.
Speaker 1: I think I've had this exact phone
call with people like this is the funniest
thing.
This it resonates so much with me.
Now, of course, what Tucker wants to be disseminating
instead of that is absolutely horrible stuff.
The the real story here is not Tucker's frustrations,
per se.
It's that it appears as though this stuff
was leaked from people associated with Fox
News directly to media matters.
And it is such a stunning turn of events when
Fox people, Fox affiliated people are leaking
things to the left wing media matters.
And we're going to see what ultimately happens
with the forthcoming with the existing and
forthcoming lawsuit against Fox News and the
role that Tucker Carlson has to play there.
I actually had I just filmed a podcast episode
with Lex Friedman very long episode, like
almost 4 hours long, pretty wide as well,
probably 3 hours wide, if you can believe
it.
And it's going to be released soon.
And we talk about the claimed reasons that
Fox fired Tucker, which have to do with politics,
which are false and the real reasons that
Fox fired Tucker, which have everything to
do with legal liability and the fact that
he's become a real problem.
This to me is just funny.
And Tucker's criticisms of Fox Nation are
absolutely spot on.
I've even been invited on Fox Nation.
And they go, Yeah, listen, we Fox producer
here, we'd like to have you on.
Oh, like which show?
Well, it's like the Fox Nation after the show,
like the bonus show equivalent.
But it's like not award winning the way ours
is.
And also there's like a guest host this week.
And I'm sorry, guys, I'm just too busy.
I'm just too busy.
I've got a, you know, a baby running around
in diapers everywhere.
It's great.
I can't do it.
I'm sorry.
I can't do it so that I very much identify
with.
All right, now let's move to.
How is the search for Tucker Carlson's replacement
going?